[Music]
hair will actually implants into your
body if you zoom in on a microscope it
looks similar to a screw there's no
other Solutions outside of surgery
I turned around and there was just this
huge chunk of Flesh that had been taken
out of my body it was sort of like
getting hit by a car I just woke up one
day and I had this disease I'm Dylan I'm
27 and I have pilonidal sinus disease
[Music]
when I was about 12 or 13 I came across
a pamphlet for the Army I made the
decision and that was exactly what I was
going to do from day one I strive to be
the fittest guy there so things like
running and working out were a huge
component of my life
I remember waking up one morning and
just feeling an immense pressure on my
lower spine that's when I had my first
surgery
I still had the mindset that I'd
finished the surgery and then I get
straight back into training however it's
it's not how it played out at all
with pilonidal sinus disease hair will
fall into your pants and your buttocks
rubbing against itself will actually
implant hair into your body and if you
zoom in on a microscope with the head it
looks similar to a screw and eventually
the friction from walking will end up
embedding that hair follicle into your
skin so a lot of people will go through
this and feel all the symptoms you know
tightness in their lower back pain while
sitting down and they won't even they
won't even realize or think to get it
checked and it can end up leading to an
infection occurring in your lower back
I was in bed for 14 months straight with
this disease it's it's called
reoccurring pilonidal sinus disease
meaning it comes back
once I had my fourth surgery I remember
waking up and I turned around in the
bathroom and looked at my lower back and
there was just this huge chunk of Flesh
that had been taken out of my body
probably the size of a small football
which was a part of the operation and I
saw that and
the hardest part of it was when that
particular surgery didn't work again and
I had to have further and further
surgeries after this and each time that
I would go in to have another surgery
not knowing what I'd wake up to and see
[Music]
I went from being this really confident
young man who was very confident in his
body image to all of a sudden you can't
sit down you can't walk I couldn't
socialize with my friends I couldn't see
my family I couldn't couldn't live life
to be completely honest with you yeah
thank you
to put some perspective in my life I
started reading books and reading about
history and other people that had gone
through severe hardships that turned
into an obsession so I'd wake up early
and I'd read books until I had to go to
the hospital I'd get back from the
hospital and continue reading I turned
reading and education into my main focus
I've got tattoos I've got a mustache not
many people would assume that this guy's
reading every single night that means
that I can have some sort of
continuation in my life when the
physical aspects of it Go most recently
I've set up a charity called brothers
and books and what it does it encourages
people to share their stories of
adversity coupled with books that have
helped them I create community libraries
with these life-changing books that
people recommend
um and I place them in places like
veteran centers and hospitals where
people are likely to be going through
hardships
I think if I was to get told that I was
having this surgery again I think now
I'm I'm equipped to deal with it
most recently I've had the top of my
butt completely cut off and I have a
large scar that runs from my lower back
all the way down
I'm uncaring about what it looks like
I'm just happy that I can get outside
again and start walking and seeing my
friends
it is your buttocks it's your butt
nobody wants to talk about your butt in
a workplace in a in a pub even talking
today is difficult
I hope that speaking about this publicly
when someone's going through this in the
future when they Google the disease it
actually comes up with something where
they can see someone else that's been
through it just to let people know that
they're not alone
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're experiencing symptoms similar
to what I've described check out the
link below